foreign
[Music]
good afternoon my name is John DeMayo
and I'm an associate professor at
Harvard Medical School and an associate
physician at Brigham and Women's
Hospital in Boston it is my pleasure
today to speak to you about sex and the
Aging lung chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease
the objectives of this talk are to
include an overview of associations with
sex and gender and lung disease and note
a role for both The genome and the
epigenome and sex differences in the
lung
I'll propose a role for networks and
network medicine as a way to integrate
sex and gender differences for the
understanding of COPD and last I hope by
the end you'll be convinced that the
path to Precision medicine for pulmonary
Diagnostics and Therapeutics is through
the science that captures sex and
gender-related causes and effects in a
holistic fashion
now COPD or chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease is a disease State
characterized by airflow obstruction
that is not fully reversible and what we
see here on this slide is two graphs the
top left shows age on the x-axis and
forced expiratory volume on the y-axis
and that is a common measure of lung
function and what we see in the red line
is this suggestion that some individuals
have accelerated lung function decline
Across the Life Course
if we look at the lower right side what
we see across that life course is that
the normal trajectory of lung function
decline includes us the development of
what's called senile emphysema a normal
aging process
but the suggestion of the development of
telomere shortening cellular senescence
and other Hallmarks of Aging put COPD in
the category of diseases associated with
age acceleration
as we Trek towards Precision medicine in
the lung and other complex diseases we
think about the compendium of risk
factors that can that accumulate Across
the Life Course starting with in utero
development proceeding Through The Game
of Life to adolescence and then finally
an advanced age with lung dysfunction
and symptomatology
and if we think in terms of sex and
gender here I present the national Vital
Statistics from 2017 males on the left
females on the right which show that
although chronic lower respiratory
disease of which COPD is at part was the
fourth leading cause of death in men it
was the third leading cause of death in
women and now in 2021 we know that covid
has supplanted the COPD rankings but it
is still a major cause of death in both
men and women
here I present an infographic from a
paper we published in Lancet last year
which separates out biologic and
gender-related differences
so sex as the biologic construct
includes those issues related to sex
chromosome complement and may impact
lung development disease pathophysiology
and this is in contradistinction to
gender related issues which capture
lifestyle socio-cultural aspects and may
include issues related to smoking
we know that lung disease is one of the
diseases that globally has been
associated with health disparities
and
what we also know is that sex
differences have been recognized as one
of the most significantly understudied
aspects of human health research
many prior experimental studies and
trials do not include equal numbers of
males and females and sex chromosomes
have generally been excluded from
genomic analyzes
in 2015 NIH guidelines suggested that we
all need to consider sex and research
design analyzes and reporting of
scientific findings and it is only
through the accounting for biologic sex
differences can we improve our
management of disease prevention and
Therapeutics
now no discussion
of COPD is complete without a discussion
of smoking and lung health
this is a beautiful paper by Don sin in
his group
it's a little bit on the older side but
it really captures the data that
persists today and it summarized the
data regarding whether women versus men
have increased susceptibility to the
effects of tobacco smoke and this was a
very comprehensive review and what it
noted was that Beyond age 45 50 female
current smokers had significantly faster
annual lung function decline than male
smokers
and this became very important in the
year 2000 and this was the first time
that the number of women dying from COPD
exceeded the number of men and this
projected increase in disease morbidity
and mortality uh has continued through
today
and what we know when these Trends and
patterns now were repeatedly studied and
this is a paper published in Jama in
2017 what we saw was a overall continued
increase in respiratory mortality
between 1980 and 2014 with the highest
mortality in the central Appalachian
Valley of the United States although
COPD mortality rates in this study were
noted to decrease nationally COPD
mortality rates in women increased more
than 100 percent
and when we look at the differences
between men and women with COPD we know
that women tend to be under-diagnosed
and sub-optimally treated that they may
differ in their disease presentation
that tobacco use susceptibility varies
and that the relationship between the
development of disease and other
exposures such as occupation and
non-occupational exposures May portend
differential risk between males and
females
we studied gender-related differences in
our lab group and this is work by Ed
Silverman where he noted that the age of
onset considerations may lead to novel
insights for understanding the
pathogenesis related to sex age and race
race differences and these are data from
the Austin early onset COPD study and
across all phases of enrollment of this
very unique cohort which included
Advanced lung disease before age 53. the
majority of participants were females
we followed this up this is research
performed by Maryland Foreman in and it
was a postdoctoral fellow at the time
and what she noted is if you look across
the age groups in the COPD Gene study
with age on the x-axis and the percent
of the cohort on the y-axis and you look
across the age fins at the youngest age
group more women had Advanced lung
disease than men so once again
reinforcing increased prevalence of
early severe disease in younger women
so we reflected on these repeated
findings and asked why this female
predominance of early onset COPD well it
could be because women have smaller
lungs than men there may be shorter
survival in men with COPD
COPD could be an x-linked dominant
disease but that doesn't seem to be the
case there could be hormonal issues
differences in tobacco smoking related
to Under reporting but none of these
seem to be the case and we were really
honing in on this idea that the
increased female susceptibility may be
by Gene by sex and gender interactions
and a complex interaction with aging
we know that if we look at studies that
have focused on the menopausal
transition that lung function declines
more rapidly at the menopausal
transition and that we urge clinicians
to be aware that respiratory health
deteriorates during reproductive aging
We performed the study again in the COPD
Gene study where we looked at
differences parsed by age less than or
greater than age 65. and in these groups
we saw that women tend to have increased
risk for shortness of breath that's
dyspnea exacerbations or periodic
worsening of their lung function and
more severe COPD and again it pointed us
towards accumulatives increasing
severity with aging
so as I noted we were honing in on this
complicated interaction between the
genome sex and advancing age
this paper is a beautiful summary of the
role of sex in genomics of human complex
traits and I urge everyone to read it
they set
genetic architecture has been described
for a host of human traits including
lung function and failing to model the
sex-specific architecture will really
hamper the detection of susceptibility
low cyprocomplex disease
up until recently ignoring the X and Y
chromosomal variance has been standard
but we really miss a whole host of
regulatory genomic interactions that may
help us better understand the
differential risk for lung disease in
men versus women
again thinking about the state of the
literature in the mid-2000s
there have been several integrated
studies of sex-specific and
gender-specific manifestations of COPD
and this data by Fernando Martinez and
his group analyzed CAT scans which are
Advanced X-rays and looked at quality of
life data from a clinical trial and they
noted that women with COPD had more
shortness of breath just had re had
noted recently and had lower reported
health status but they also demonstrated
that women have less emphysema which is
a very destructive phenotype and when
they look at the histology of the lung
women had thicker Airways so this idea
started to to be
suggested that maybe emphysema is a
phenotype of men
so we investigated this and looked at
sex-specific features of emphysema in
the COPD Gene study
and if you focus on the histograms on
the right when we looked at all subjects
it was true that men had on average more
emphysema but when we looked at in
subgroups with early onset disease
severe emphysema or Advanced lung
disease there was no difference so
emphysema is not a phenotype of men and
we looked at the genetics of this and
described a sex-specific association
with emphysema in women in the Seltzer
one gene but not in men and this Seltzer
one gene is quite interesting because it
had previously been linked to normal
lung branching morphogenesis which is a
key developmental stage in lung in the
lung again we were heading into this
idea not only about aging but maybe sex
specific aspects of lung development May
portend differential risk for disease
and as we were advancing this idea of
the investigation of the genetics by sex
or COPD I started thinking about this
idea of the evolution of sex differences
in human disease and I think this paper
by Morrow and colleagues says it best
we don't really expect that the general
phenomenon of sex differences to be
related to the genetic alphabet or
genetic variation because the genetic
material is shared but maybe it is
related to the epigenome
and the epigenome broadly defined are
elements that may change the expression
of the gene without changing DNA
sequence and we started pursuing the
investigation of DNA methylation which
is one example of an epigenetic
variation
we looked at smoking Associated
site-specific differential methylation
in cheek cells in the buccal mucosa and
we compared male and female results for
differential methylation at the sip1b1
Gene and sip 1v1 is interesting because
it is a genobia is a xenobiotic
metabolizer of cigarette smoke and what
we observed was that differential
methylation at this Gene was associated
with lower lung function this is fev one
percent predicted lower ratio of fev1 to
force vial capacity as well as percent
emphysema in women not men
and we followed it up looking at lung
tissue and what we observed when we
looked across the genome with chromosome
on the x-axis and and the negative log
of a p-value for a genome-wide DNA
methylation evaluation there were a lot
of differential methylation marks in
lung tissue that varied by sex and when
we modeled a sex by smoking interaction
we saw several marks had different
directions of effect between males and
females again bringing us to this idea
that maybe it's the regulatory genome
that's important for sex differences in
COPD
we've also looked at the metabolome and
this is a paper that was recently
published looking at metabolomic
differences between men and women with
and without COPD and we identified a
whole host of metabolites that were
different between men and women
so when we think in terms of of the
canonical Pathways that take us from DNA
variation to proteomic expression we
think in terms of layers of the genome
and when we think in terms of layers of
the genome we think of a network
and we're very interested in network and
systems biology approaches brought to
there in understanding lung disease so
what is a network what is Network
medicine Network medicine
broadly represents as defined in this
paper by Laszlo veravasi is the study of
cellular disease and social networks
which aims to quantify the complex
interactions contributing to individual
disease
and a real unique aspect about Network
medicine is that it's holistic rather
than reductionistic it allows us to take
the compendium of molecular disease
layers and construct a comprehensive
model it may allow us to capture
non-linear effects and emerging
properties and it broadly employs
systems biology methods and we've
thought about this in in several
different ways as we thought about the
sex and gender
findings related to causes of death as
we thought about gender differences and
sex differences in cancer the
differential methylation and we emerged
upon this idea that we should look at
sex differences in gene expression and
Regulatory networks first in the in
normal tissue
and and we had started thinking about
this in 2014 and this is a paper by
Kimberly glass in our group and what we
did was we built Gene regulatory
networks in men and women with COPD and
what we broadly observed is that whether
we looked in sputum
so
hopefully representing the lung or if we
looked in blood we could build Gene
regulatory networks that identified
different nodes and Edge connections for
females in pink and males and blue
we scaled this up to
Consortium data and we built
8279 single Networks
we first looked at differential gene
expression in these samples across 29
tissues and on average except for the
sex chromosomes we did not see broad
differences in sex in sex-specific gene
expression across all the tissues
however when we built Gene regulatory
networks we saw that although on average
there was no differential gene
expression there was a big difference in
how genes were targeted between men and
women and so the way I like to phrase
this is that the genes end up in the
same location but the road they took to
get there seemed to be different between
men and women so a gene regulatory
network is one way to try to understand
sex differences in lung disease we also
looked at co-expression networks and
we've built comethylation networks
looking at correlation between
methylation and we first started to do
this in lung tissue again going back to
the Aging hypothesis we built lung
tissue correlation networks from DNA
methylation data in both fetal lung
tissue fetal lung DNA methylation and
adult lung tissue from adults with
chronic obstructive pulmonary disease
and what we revealed is that there was a
lot of similarity in the networks
between the fetal lung and early life
and COPD in later life focused on wind
hippo and other Pathways that have been
related to aging as well as lung disease
and this is a paper published by one of
my postdoctoral fellows Priya khatru and
what we saw was that DNA methylation
perturbations May link development and
aging in the lung and bringing this all
together we've also observed these
findings for sex differences as well
so bringing it all together we really
start to see across the layers of the
genome
features we can develop starting with
DNA variation DNA methylation gene
expression metabolomics proteomics and
then a holistic Network we start to see
evidence that COPD is a disease of Aging
it's a disease of sex differences it's a
disease of sex differences that may
start in utero and progress Across the
Life Course and it's a disease that is
differentially impacted by environmental
exposures such as cigarette smoke
between men and women across the life
course
so why is this interesting why is this
important it really brings us to
clinical considerations I'm a
pulmonologist and we know that women
carry the excess burden from COPD in
terms of being younger with Advanced
disease they have more shortness of
breath for similar levels of lung
function impairment increase health care
utilization and this has therapeutic
implications we know that women may have
increased susceptibility to tobacco
smoke and I should say that both men and
women should stop smoking it's never too
late
but we know that smoking cessation may
bring about
greater Improvement in lung function in
women
Aging in the lung with differences by
sex may drive the differences we see in
COPD and we really need to give
consideration of modeling the molecular
targets drug responses the networks with
sex and gender aware approaches
so other groups have been converging on
the idea of Aging in the lung as a
driver of COPD and and Dr Peter Barnes
in the UK has really been the champion
of this concept of COPD as a disease of
accelerated aging and
this is only a small set of the papers
but it really points to this idea of
xenotherapy or aging pathway targets as
a New Horizon for COPD Therapeutics
and and
this is a really important concept as we
think of taking genomic medicine to
Precision medicine I think the most
convincing way to do that is to realize
and internalize the idea that men and
women may require different therapeutic
responses if we're really going to use
genomics and genomic insights to develop
Precision approaches to preventative and
and therapeutic approaches
so what is the next next decade Bring
It's a next the next decade is clearly
one of
you look towards Big genomic data
advances in machine learning the
development of polygenic risk scores
we know that better phenotyping of study
subjects and subtyping using Next
Generation analytics is really going to
advance us even closer towards Precision
medicine
we have the opportunity to address sex
and gender differences related to the
progression of multiple domains or
multiple phenotypes together with aging
we can think in terms of the development
of subgroup specific Therapeutics
but we can also be Visionary and think
of ways to use our insights into the
genome and the networks for prevention
of lung disease with careful
considerations about for prevention
starting with in utero susceptibilities
and this is very timely because we're
very concerned about the continued
emergence of sex and gender related
differences in lung disease related to
vaping and electronic cigarette use and
this is an area for further study
so as I think in terms of my own hope I
really hope we can bring together
all of the elements we've discussed in
this talk today
thinking in terms of development as an
early
stage of Aging thinking in terms of sex
hormones what happens at Key transitions
in life between menopause or the
andropause in men
bringing together the layers from
genetics epigenetics transcriptomics
proteomics and metabolomics and putting
them together in a sex
and gender aware omic framework to
really get to this eventuality for both
biomarkers and Therapeutics for
precision pulmonary medicine
so thank you for for your attention
I received funding for work in Sex and
gender differences in the lung disease
from the National Institutes of Health
from the Berlin Women's Hospital Connors
Center I have an ignite award for the
development of sex specific Therapeutics
the Alpha One Foundation and these are
my institutional affiliations and I
thank you for your attention
foreign